Nos dicen que: "La primera energía de ionización
de la plata (Ag) es 7.31 x 10⁵ J/mol. ¿Cuál es la
longitud de onda de luz más larga que es capaz de
ionizar un átomo de plata en fase gaseosa?" Muy
bien, ahora, incluso antes de que te pida hacer
una pausa y tratar de resolver esto por tu cuenta,
recordemos o tratemos de entender qué es la
primera energía de ionización. Esta es la
energía necesaria para conseguir que el electrón
más externo o de mayor energía escape del átomo,
entonces el electrón no sólo va a ir a un nivel
de energía más alto sino que va a escapar por
completo; podrías verlo como el nivel de energía
infinito. Y la razón por la que estamos hablando
de la longitud de onda de la luz más larga
es porque, recuerda: cuanto más larga es la
longitud de onda menor es la frecuencia y menor
la energía. Esto realmente se refiere a cuál es la
frecuencia mínima o la energía mínima asociada con
la longitud de onda de luz más larga para un átomo
de plata. Hay un par de cosas a las que prestar
atención. Nos están dando la primera energía de
ionización en términos de moles, no por átomo, y
tenemos que recordar todas las diferentes formas
de relacionar la longitud de onda, la frecuencia
y la energía. Ahora, teniendo todo esto en mente,
te invito a que pauses este video y trates
de resolverlo. ¿Cuál es la longitud de onda
de luz más larga que es capaz de ionizar un
átomo de plata en fase gaseosa? Muy bien,
ahora trabajemos juntos en esto. Entonces, lo
primero que debes hacer es intentar calcular la
primera energía de ionización por átomo, y tal
vez lo escriba así. Entonces la primera energía
de ionización por átomo será igual a la energía
de ionización: 7.31 x 10⁵ J/mol. Pero ¿qué pasa
si queremos calcular por átomo, esto es por mol?
Bueno, ¿cuántos moles hay por átomo? Sabemos que
hay esta cantidad de átomos por mol, así que
si queremos conocer los moles por átomo será 1
mol por cada 6.022 x 10²³ átomos. Podría escribir
átomos aquí y luego eso nos daría Jules por átomo,
pero obtendremos la respuesta en términos de
Jules, porque los moles se cancelarán. Entonces
esto nos va a dar aproximadamente, veamos: 7.31
multiplicado por 10⁵ / 6.022 multiplicado por
10²³ es igual a... Y aquí tenemos tres cifras
significativas, es aproximadamente igual a 1.21
x 10¯¹⁸, y las unidades aquí son Jules, son Jules
por átomo. Entonces, ¿cómo averiguamos la longitud
de onda? Bueno, como mencioné, vamos a querer usar
estas ecuaciones de aquí. Sabemos que la velocidad
de la luz es igual a la longitud de onda de esa
luz multiplicada por la frecuencia de la luz. Esta
es la letra griega minúscula nu [v], no es una
v. Entonces, si queremos encontrar la longitud
de onda, simplemente dividimos ambos lados entre
la frecuencia y así se obtiene que la longitud de
onda, es igual a la velocidad de la luz dividida
entre la frecuencia. Pero ¿cómo se calcula
la frecuencia a partir de la energía? Bueno,
eso es lo que nos da esta ecuación de arriba:
la energía es igual a la Constante de Planck
multiplicada por la frecuencia. Entonces,
si queremos encontrar la frecuencia vamos
a dividir ambos lados entre la Constante de
Planck. Y para que la ecuación superior se pueda
reescribir como frecuencia, la escribiré aquí:
la frecuencia es igual a la energía dividida entre
la Constante de Planck. Después podemos tomar esto
y sustituirlo aquí, y tenemos que nuestra longitud
de onda es igual a la velocidad de la luz dividida
entre la energía dividida entre la Constante de
Planck, o simplemente podemos reescribir esto
como igual a la velocidad de la luz multiplicada
por la Constante de Planck dividida entre... Trato
de mantener el código de colores. Dividido entre
la energía. Bueno, sabemos cuál es la velocidad
de la luz, es aproximadamente 2.998 x 10 ⁸ m/s.
Multiplicamos esto por la Constante de Planck,
que es 6.626 x 10¯³⁴ Js, y luego vamos a dividir
esto entre la primera energía de ionización
por átomo que calculamos aquí. Así que vamos a
dividir esta E de aquí. Esto ya lo calculamos:
1.21 x 10¯¹⁸ J. Ahora asegurémonos de que todas
las unidades funcionen, así que estos segundos
se cancelarán con estos segundos, estos Jules se
cancelarán con estos Jules, y sólo nos quedaremos
con metros, lo cual tiene sentido. La longitud de
onda se puede medir en metros, así que saquemos
nuestra calculadora y calculemos lo que va a ser:
2.998 multiplicado por 10⁸ x 6.626 multiplicado
por 10¯³⁴ y luego dividiré eso entre 1.21 x 10¯¹⁸.
Creo que merecemos un redoble de tambores, eso nos
da esto. Y si tenemos tres cifras significativas,
porque es la cantidad más pequeña en este cálculo,
vamos a considerar estas tres de aquí, y entonces
esto va a ser 1.64 x 10 a la menos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7; entonces esto va a ser aproximadamente
igual a 1.64 x 10¯⁷ metros. Y hemos terminado.